I can't believe I'm saying this ready
Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg are dead
serious about a cage match UFC president
Dana White says I think he's confused on
what a gimmick fight is
is it going to be one of the most
watched fights of all time yes does that
make it not a gimmick no this is the
definition of a gimmick fight
Brandon
what's up fam Monday morning we are back
the whole thick boy team went on a
little vacation last week
uh I didn't I was here Casey was here
chin was in uh
no damn it not Tokyo how dare you Seoul
South Korea man that's right yeah there
you go how was it it was amazing was it
though yeah it was amazing it's it's and
the food's good everything it's great
food's amazing just walking around is
amazing family was great it was just a
beautiful time really yeah how long were
you out there
five days it takes like a day to get
there and a day to get back so five days
Beast yeah glad you had fun buddy did
you feel refreshed was it a good break
for you it was a beautiful break so
thank you for that too it was I mean it
was a beautiful break for sure yeah
Brian was in Jerusalem some [__] I don't
know camels Israel some [__] but I was
gone for 10 days
uh Georgia went back to Chicago to see
his mama he hasn't been back since
tall George went to Nashville with his
brother to the tight end U thing which
is cool for him
in the main case we're here baby in case
you're grinding baby no break for us
case played golf I assume yeah golf and
work man that's what we do daddy uh in
the fight we're like going on in the
fight world since uh Alaska saw you guys
all you viewers out there a lot is going
on a lot of drama there were some fights
uh over the weekend there's some fights
coming up nothing that's gonna knock
your dick in the dirt let's be honest
here the cards have been pretty watered
down but there's been some uh important
fights I should say in each division but
again for the casuals out there nothing
that's gonna make you sit on your couch
and cancel your Saturday night plans
I'll say it put it that way but if
you're degenerate like me and watch it
all I'm excited I'm into it
um so yeah you had uh topuria and Josh
Emmett fight this past weekend in the
featherweight division in Portland the
featherweight division Josh Emmett
cannot catch a break uh Elia topira
looked absolutely amazing I mean shutout
win did you watch it Jen I did yeah you
watch a case this dude is the real feel
undefeated
um he had a premier league royalty with
him
um he had a very what's the guy's name I
don't know but it's very famous soccer
players very famous soccer he even looks
like a soccer player Ilya he looks like
a he could be a soccer a little bit if
they're really short and small
um but
um what the [__] that guy's name my
girl's all up on his nuts I'm sure it's
on the UFC Instagram
uh yeah the baby they might have missed
that ball
it should be though
I'm pretty sure it is I mean Superstar
dude
this guy there is yes that oh Sergio
Ramos I mean Legend dude
this guy but bro the majority of
Americans don't even know this ledge I
mean he's like he's Tom Cruise in Spain
he's
massive son massive
oh my 60 million followers you ever
heard of him yeah he's a dime piece too
yeah he was there he announced he was
coming he looked very similar to the guy
in his corner I thought he was working
his corner I'm like that doesn't make
sense but good for him but topiria
looked absolutely amazing I would assume
what's next for him is the winner of uh
Yaya Rodriguez and volkonovsky I I don't
know where you go after I mean I
wouldn't say a shutout I had it 50
50 42 I'm fine with it was a bully beat
down I mean it was even close you know
it didn't go well for Emmett who
Emmett's the legend I love him but you
know it didn't go away oh God is he
tough that's what you know it was a long
night in the officer man I can take a
punch that's not good it's not good when
you walk back after fighting in the UFC
you get back into your uh little you
know Corner Room there in the red or
blue corner where all the setup is in
the back after fighting goes no one will
not say you're not tough dude you're
like God God damn I lost that fight
whenever that's the first comment man
that guy's tough I don't understand I
got buddies like oh my God that fight
was amazing like I didn't think it was
amazing amazing
outing for topiria he looked amazing he
looked yeah he looked fantastic but if
you're an Emmy fan like man this they
should have thrown in the towel man like
man he's just getting his ass whooped
and the Corner's like you ready to go
he's like yeah and gets back out there
and gets his ass whooped I don't get it
be like man look at the heart on this
guy it's like I guess it's not good dude
it's not good so for Ilia it's yeah it's
I think tile shot her bust you look at
the division you got Max Holloway Korean
zombie fighting if okanovski bti
Rodriguez which I think he does but if
he doesn't you got yeah Rodriguez Max
Hollywood be fun but they fought before
um and then you can't do Max versus
volkanovski for a fourth time so for
Ilia topiria it makes the most sense
it just the stars have a line for him to
get a title shot
Arnold Allen coming off a loss yeah it
doesn't make sense so I think he's right
there right there I would assume he gets
the next title shot rightfully so he
looked [__] fantastic Macy Barber
looked amazing got her combo with the
head kick to the follow-up she looked
absolutely amazing so she's coming out
of the flyweight division as a real
contend to the color may see the future
Barber the future is now me lady Futures
now Austin Lane Justin tafa I was
excited for Austin Lane Austin Lane was
a guy who played for the Jacksonville
Jaguars football player and he said cool
man check out this eye poke and it was a
brutal eye poke so that was a bummer Neo
magni flew into the radar but he got it
done again via decision
other than that man not a lot going on
in the fight world uh the Ilia tapira
and Macy Barber the stars of that but uh
Ilya should get a title shot next
outside that man again the Summers the
Fulfillment cards you know they have to
contractually but outside that and then
you get the paper used the cards coming
up are good that's all they're doing
they're just they're just edginess until
we get to those pay-per-views that's all
they're doing this weekend's card not
great Sean Strickland fighting a guy we
can't pronounce his name you know and
he's probably gonna beat him Sean
Strickland as tough as they [__] come
uh let's try it I'll be spin Mega Madoff
I'll be spend my gametov I like
made of not bad right yeah not bad at
all Sean Strickland
yeah some [__] Russian or German is
the flag they had up on uh did you go to
share dog Jane how dare you they had
cheer dog it's like a German flag he's
not German though and now it's right now
it's Russian that's a it's clearly
Russian so Sean Strickland fighting
another Russian dude that's gonna be you
know a nightmare of a matchup but some
way he's gonna get it done probably dude
what are the odds on this I would assume
Strickland's a slight favorite
there it is go up
uh yep Sean trigger than minus 175. that
makes sense
that makes sense
shall waiting for that July 8th hitter
that heavy hitter the big ass
pay-per-view July 8th is fun it's a
Russian argon Argan
I don't know what that is but yeah it's
25-4 that's so Russian do you know any
Russian that doesn't have at least 20
wins it's just they just have zero
losses yeah they just be fighting dude
fighting uh yeah so hopefully John
Strickland gets it done
rest cards whatever
lipsky never matter when she fights him
at Griffin's fun Grant Dawson
um Kevin Lee returns fun
foreign
it's impossible that's what it is Jen
he looks pretty crazy he's 20 and one
chin there you go yeah there you go
now his name doesn't seem oh he's
Russian okay these [__] Russians dude
again how many wins 20 one loss Hey
Kevin Lee here's this guy
can only we'll give you half your win
bonus you can just pronounce his last
name you know that's where we're at dude
that's where it's at in the UFC right
now
that's a tough one but there's a lot
else going outside of just these fight
nights uh you got a lot of drama going
on in the world of MMA the biggest news
I'm sure it's your first current event
Chad
dude this made me laugh so chin you know
whenever he brings care to vets it's
like MMA junkie MMA fighting uh is from
all these Outlets
yep you know you know bloody up share
dog this one's from people.com that's
how you know it's mainstream
I can't believe I'm saying this ready
Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg are dead
serious about a cage match UFC president
Dana White says
um and then Dana continued I forget he
had an interview with uh maybe TMZ he
was like this is not a gimmick
excuse me sir
now I'm not saying I'm not gonna watch
it I would watch these two the literally
the worst bodies in all of sports
um so so Davis is him firing back people
then keep watching MMA versus Boxer and
boxing apparently you love those fights
even though you know exactly who's gonna
win all good no this is a gimmick fight
don't argue with someone like this dude
I love doing massive fights that
everyone want to see this is one of the
biggest fights of all time fun [__] so I
think
um this isn't a gimmick fight gimmick is
that maybe guys
this gimmick is MMA guys go in the box
and getting beat we have seen already
and Know How It Ends this is a fight
between two of the most powerful richest
guys in the world who will win who have
seen this before nobody it's also a
crossover fight that literally everyone
will watch
so I think he's confused on what a
gimmick fight is is it going to be one
of the most watched fights of all time
yes does that make it not a gimmick no
this is the definition of a gimmick
fight you have two guys that have no
business fighting
what makes it a gimmick too and this is
this is again gives me my Spidey Sense
goes off I just think Dana White's bored
I think he's over the regular UFC
matchups I think that's why you have the
power slap Fight League I think that's
why he's even entertaining Mark
Zuckerberg Elon Musk in the UFC he's
just bored he's over it he's made his
money it's kind of this smooth sailing
machine right now he just wants to mix
it up and this is another project for
him to do he'll be associated with one
of the big I don't think it happens by
the way just be completely transparent I
don't think this happens but what I do
think is Dana wants to be involved in
one of the biggest
fights of all time he wants to be in the
middle of it which he would be
to call this not a gimmick is absolutely
stupid insane especially this come from
a guy Dana that did a press conference
shortly you know just people must have
forgot two weeks ago when it's like you
know I would never make uh Francis Gano
Tyson Fury these gimmick fights we don't
do that here that's not what we do here
that's not what I'm the business of
excuse me sir then a week later he's
like Jon Jones Tyson fear I'm down for
that
Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk I'm down for
that I just think he's bored that's all
this is I think he's bored as [__] I
think he wants to be in the middle of it
I think he likes that uh Elon Musk and
Mark Zuckerberg instead of saying let's
box each other said let's fight each
other in the UFC I think Dana likes that
uh notoriety I think he likes being the
conversation I think he's a bit of a
[__] let's be honest that's all
this is it's an ego check for him it's
an ego fight I I think what makes it the
biggest gimmick too
is let's say Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg had any other background in a
sport pick a sport NBA basketball let's
say they played basketball growing up
let's say they played uh football
growing up clearly they these guys that
didn't know athletic achievements as
children growing up rightfully so
they're both two of the smartest men to
ever live cool you don't have to do that
stuff but let's just say they played
soccer pick any sport soccer football
for you uh non-americans out there
um basketball uh or regular American
football can you imagine
if Elon Musk is powerful as famous as he
is and Mark Zuckerberg called up I don't
know uh pick at any team the Los Angeles
Rams and we're like hey
we want to participate in the game this
season we would love I bet you I could
complete a past Mark Zuckerberg against
the 49ers do you think there's any
[__] chance any other league if the
NBA
like hey we want to me and Mark
Zuckerberg this is Elon talking means
Mark Zuckerberg want to play one-on-one
against each other and put it on the NBA
network and we want you guys to promote
it and get everybody there you think any
other league would entertain this okay
MLB I bet you I can get a home run off
Mark Zuckerberg will you ear it on the
MLB Network during your home run derby
during the All-Star week every single
major league would say kick [__] that's
not what we do here you kidding me we're
a real League here man this is a gambik
only in the UFC is this even uh [__]
viable option dude it's embarrassing
it's just embarrassing
I'm not saying I wouldn't watch it I'm
not saying that then that's why it will
do great views my dad would watch it my
grandma would watch it my aunt would
watch it you're not going to get good
product you can see these two soy boys
fight it out that's all you're going to
do the two richest guys you're gonna
realize that there's a reason why they
don't take on athletic Ventures
um do not call it a gimmick is laughable
that's what this is I think we're
confusing on there's a there's been a
lot of gimmicks that get a ton of views
and make a ton of money that doesn't
mean it's not a gimmick this is the
biggest gimmick in the world that's all
this is I don't think it happens I
honestly gun to the Head this fight does
not happen not a chance but to even
entertain it just shows you at the level
that mma's still it's still in infancy
days we're just not there it shows you
we're not a big major sport no other
league no other Commissioner of any of
these leagues would ever entertain any
competition like this just shows you
where Dana White's at it's sad to me
I think it also shows you where
mma's at this isn't a knock on the UFC
it's just MMA in general is down across
the board in the United States MMA
contents down uh fights are down
viewerships down pay-per-views are down
now people get confused too with this
and same thing with you know this to get
make a lot of money get a lot of views
not a gimmick no that that's the
definition of a gimmick this fight and
also people go how can you say MMA views
are down they've made more money than
they've ever made last year yes but not
predicate off viewership they made more
money based off advertisement and the
ESPN deal not viewership
is on the decline across the board I
think it's because a there's no off
season
B there's too many fights C it's not the
big names that that we want to see
because they have to fulfill the
contract of ESPN so that you're getting
these watered-down fights you might know
the main event outside that they're kind
of going to a box and did where you have
one fight that you know of and the rest
you've never heard of it's just just
feeding you all the stuff there's no off
season so I think it's just fatigue of
the fan base we're like Jesus Christ now
in here we love fighting so it's hell
yeah great but the Mass is like no
another one
there's no off season there's no rest I
think that's why pfl Bellator will never
make it there's not enough there's not
enough people on in the United States
not even the world that love fighting
that much that want to see it every
single weekend with no off season
no other sport does this
it's fatigue of the audience there's too
many there's too much
some people go with pfl and Bellator
combine what happens nothing there's not
enough audience for them to survive
it's not there's a top dog it would be
better if there was just one
organization I hate to tell you it'd be
better if Bellator and pfl just fold in
the UFC be better for everybody nobody
else is going to make it nobody else
makes any money look at all their look
all their numbers across the board pfl
Bellator name a league nobody's making
money but the UFC
it's not a fans in the world it's just
not that they give a [__] and there's no
off season every single week it doesn't
make you special
so it's just a fatigue of the audience
that's all it is I do agree with you as
far as if all the promotions just became
one of course that'd be the best
possible thing right but I think when I
looked at Bellator because I have to
look at you know obviously the fights
that are coming up Bellator doesn't have
that many fights coming up that off
that's because they're in transaction of
getting sold they're gonna sell
yeah they did say that they're in the
market for yeah they're potentially pfl
yeah pfl and there's some other ones too
and pfl is like you people think pfl is
a for sure thing it's not
that's not for sure thing yeah nothing's
for sure no but all of it you know
yeah but I mean yeah literally if it was
one organization that would be badass
well it's it's like you look at the look
at the NFL the Rocks trying to whatever
is UFL or XFL XFL I don't think it's
doing well of course it's not no we're
good hold on let me get this straight
I can watch the very best players in the
world play and there's an off scene but
when they're in season I watch them
Monday Thursday Sunday and then when
there's not a season you want me to
watch you guys I've never heard of
the audience isn't there we're good man
we're good they're never gonna make it
never gonna make it
there's too much other [__] else to
watch
Bellator is never going to make it pfl
is never going to make it
this is the UFC or Bust it is what it is
it's fatigue of the sport
is across the masses again I'm not
talking to people probably watching this
show or the people in the air we watch
everything the majority of the world
does not do they have lives they move on
there's no off season
sounds so somber it's not though but
these other leagues trying to do it's
like why why hasn't another NBA popped
up they've tried it yeah yeah there's
only one NBA dude we're good why hasn't
Bellator why didn't strike force why
didn't Affliction why didn't Pride why
and pride was Boomer at the time they
got them fold them into the UFC
Strikeforce foam in the UFC
Bellator look at all these leaks popping
up why aren't they making it we're good
dude we want to see these guys that we
know and they're the best and they put
on how many [__] shows a year and now
you want to add more of a watered down
product and think you're gonna make it
it's terrible [__] idea
but pfl is going to do it really explain
how
look at their champions
don't break look it up chin name two
champions in pfl
name two
champions in pfl uh this is another VA
no I don't know if Olivia Albion he's
not a champion I don't know if he's
champ yeah I don't know yep case can you
name two
kisses no and it's our job that's what
we're doing here yeah
right yeah it's true who's gonna watch
that
that's the thing which doesn't help them
right only their social media my watch
highlights there's a reason there's one
NHL there's a reason why there's one NFL
there's a reason why there's one NBA
you have one League that represents the
best of the best
across the land everyone else is just
second rate in the audience we're good
the audience is letting you know we're
good dude
yeah I mean we can afford to buy
the Bellator Showtime whatever thing we
can buy
um
because I don't have regular TV but the
only thing I actually purchased is
literally just UFC ESPN plus UFC that's
it yeah you're like most people most
people aren't gonna search out for the
CFL when the NFL's going on most people
aren't searching out I don't even know
another League I don't know the G League
this is the only sport I watch so but
with any sport like you're not seeking
out on a Saturday Sunday afternoon the
XFL or the hell it's called No you don't
give a [__] no but what I'm saying is
like this is the only sport I watched is
the only sport I love and I'm only
buying ESPN plus and UFC pay-per-views I
don't yeah they buy like big you know
big fights I'll buy every now and then
but this is what I stick to the most
yeah and this isn't a knock on those
other leagues in the fighters some of
their Fighters definitely can compete in
UFC might be able to beat some of their
Champions it doesn't matter
let's take a little break y'all this
episode of the shop show is brought to
you by my friends at happy hippo
listen I use happy Apple every single
day whether I'm doing podcasting stand
up just out with the kiddos helps me
tackle my busy schedule being a pops and
also running thick boy Studios honestly
the best way to describe it it's not
like if you drink some crazy caffeinated
uh liquid it's not like that you get
this warm balance just zoned in feeling
my favorites are the high concentrated
shots I use the sour apple they have uh
to the first ever to market the k-dips
Kratom and pouches if you use pouches
like I do for other products they have
it in Kratom they're 20 milligrams they
have Wintergreen they have the Razzle
Dazzle blue which I prefer the first
ever Market K dips are available right
now at happy hippo go to happyhippo.com
they have gummies powders everyone get
your Kratom Whatever Gets you in that
flow State let happy hippo get you the
only company that I trust try out the
new k-dips right now go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick23
that's t-h-i-c-c-c 23 you twin soft for
Life share with your friend share with
brother your aunt whoever it's the best
created on the planet it's the only
creator of my trust happyhippo.com
you're welcome this episode of the shop
show is brought to you by the one the
only the tried and true we're talking
about on its supplements but not just
supplements talking about the best
nootropic on the planet you've heard of
it you've heard me talk about a million
times you see it out there on the
streets we're talking about Alpha Brain
they sold over a million freaking
bottles of alpha Brands how good it is
and if you don't trust it cool you have
no risk there you can try it out if you
don't love it they will refund your
money you don't have to send back the
Alpha Brain they'll refund your money no
questions asked share it with a buddy if
you don't love it but you're missing out
because Alpha Brain is the number one
nootropic on the planet AIDS in mental
processing it's caffeine free helps
promote the Flow State promotes Focus
supports memory helps you react more
click quickly also remember names and
places who couldn't use some of that I
have on it uh regular which you see in
like Walmarts and Whole Foods they have
the Alpha Brain Black which I use the
highly concentrated Alpha Brain Alpha
Brain instant Alpha Brain shot we got it
all go to audit.com you get temps off
all Alpha Brain products and all on it
workout gear they're protein powders
their Warrior bars they're clubs they're
steel maces they're streaming Fitness
best One-Stop shop to get your thick ass
in shape for this summer go to audit.com
you receive 10 off all off marine
products all the workout gear all the
workout supplements audit.com shop 10
off now let's get back to the program
yeah it's interesting point is is this
fight's a gimmick yeah so that's what it
comes down to this fight's a gimmick
yeah I I mean you don't want to watch it
but you'd watch it I think everyone
would be really really sad with the
product that you get you get this doughy
Mark Zuckerberg this nerd walking out
trying to make a serious face scared
shitless there's never been a real
competition in his life Elon Musk
walking out he's a robot for all we know
but still has tits very strange he's
walking out and I like I like Elon I
don't like Zuckerberg can kiss his ass
but I love Elon so it's like and neither
one has been in high level competition
you know how tired they're gonna get
after two minutes in the first round
it's gonna be three five minute rounds
or we're gonna make sure this thing's
again we can do three two minute rounds
or do you want to do three one minute
rounds because we know these boys can't
make it how far do you want to take this
gimmick then is it a full card do you
toss them on a major pay-per-view UFC do
you to toss them on a Izzy card who's
gonna headline there is is he the
headline into the co-main event this has
to be the headliner regardless yeah sure
so would you put it on what do you what
do you do with a huge pay-per-view yeah
you put on ESPN I guess it's just
regular UFC pay-per-view but it'd be
like that's just one fight no no of
course the build the card discuss [__]
YouTube
disgusting it'll be huge though the
reality is it will be huge we would all
watch it sure yeah I would watch Brad
Pitt and George Clooney exactly exactly
would it be great no but it doesn't need
to be in the UFC I know that's my point
it didn't have to that's insane but
that's where it becomes a gimmick
but these guys would want there's no way
Elon Musk and uh Zuckerberg are fighting
in LFA or they're going to fight in the
UFC they would have to find UFC because
it's the biggest organization just like
you're saying it's the biggest
organization that's what they want the
you know and that's why they shouldn't
be allowed to fight that's my point you
know what I'm saying this is so weird I
don't think it's gonna happen anyways I
don't think it's gonna happen the point
is I think people should
whether you care or not your your ear
should be up because this is where Dana
White's at
he's so over making the best fighters on
the planet fight he's so he's been doing
so long he's achieved everything he's
the top of Mount Everest he's
entertaining this this is a guy that
wouldn't let Roy Jones Jr in his prime
fight Anderson silvioles that's not what
we do here
he's so far down the road he's like yeah
I'll put Elon versus Mark Zuckerberg
over Jon Jones
you know what I'm saying that's where
we're at dude it's not good it's a slap
in the face to everybody across the
board speaking of Jon Jones
so Jon Jones tweeted out that he's team
Zuck let me know if you need a trading
partner and then GSP says
he's a huge huge fan of Elon and would
love to help him out
so even the biggest Legends in the game
are you know of course everyone's trying
to write everyone's trying to write the
coattails exactly so that's exactly and
I honestly I think you know Dana does
Dana knows it's probably not gonna
happen but he he's gonna the market as
much as possible yeah of course all
these guys yo let me know if you need
help yeah hey Zuckerberg if you're in
why wouldn't you though if you're in
Calabasas come on down I wouldn't suck
my dick dude
yeah if Elon said Brennan can you help
me with striking hell yeah okay
here we go boys real fight and you see
me on the countdown Elon wants this man
I'll tell you right this is not a
gimmick this is not a gimmick he wants
this and you know he puts his mind
something he's gonna get it done I'm
telling you man this guy's obsessed with
MMA and we know who Elon listen he's
he's my trips to the Moon you don't
think he can figure Jujitsu out I would
be sad
striking you know me and Dana talked the
other night it's it's insane how into
this He Is We we talked all through the
night how important this is to Elon man
and he's done everything in his power to
get ready for this fight and to be
honest if he was younger decide I think
he'd be top five of all time that's what
the [__] you're gonna hear yeah of
course
I'm curious what like
I'm so curious like what if if Rogan's
even entertain this
Brogan likes the circus you know he'll
be like oh it's interesting it'd be good
do it but also there has to be some sort
of
there have to be some sort of like the
line has to be drawn somewhere right
guys like there has to be what's next
made a statement on it but yeah I don't
know if he does if he does if Dana's
into something you know he's very close
with Dan he just won't say anything he
thinks it's complete [__] that's
what good friends do like yeah I'm not
whatever this is stupid
yeah but every every UFC fighter I mean
I get it fellas we gotta we gotta eat
every hey Mark if Zuckerberg if you need
somebody bro hit me up all the Twitter
I'll tell him to kiss this dick
you evil piece of [__]
all right we done with this one yeah man
all right cool
so Connor apparently Conor missed the
deadline for the usada thing for him to
fight this year so Conor did a post and
he deleted it and I'll show you what he
said here
right there
y'all shut up and wait silence Roar from
the throne patience peasants and then it
goes on here bring proverb 12 Forge our
Stout
till the sport bring me gold and plunder
only buzzing soon loves just thanks for
the love ham God
yeah I I don't know I think everyone
thinks they're not fighting no they're
not fighting yeah I'm finally convinced
that it's probably not happening and the
the alternate fighter ratings are so low
um because they didn't do anything to
change it's the same show it's so lame
doesn't give a [__] yeah like even
Wonder Boy Thompson he went there on the
last episode to help him Coach he's like
are you actually gonna coach today I
think he he didn't mean to say but they
put up it's on tape he's like are you
actually like help coach the kids today
or he's like yeah I'll be in there you
can tell he's just like hey man he's my
face I'm not here I'm here to party in
Vegas and do my thing
again his guy gets annihilated they're
0-3 yeah well
so it like think it think of this like
the top two
news events you brought chin this is
where we're at right now in MMA
Mark zuckers Elon Musk is it gonna
happen is it a gimmick fight
Conor McGregor misses the usada not
fighting this year boom that's where
we're at
okay
um as far as there's a bunch of new belt
announcements I'm sure this happened
like a week or so ago we talked about
yeah you know what I'm talking about yes
so the first one is uh Henry Henry
sahuto versus Marlon Vera yeah so who
knows hurt though so yeah so they agreed
verbally but it's not a contract signed
yet or contract inside but verbal
agreements are both on both sides that
means it's happening UFC goes you're in
[__]
that's a great fight yeah top fight for
uh Cheeto yeah
that's what Sean O'Malley said too he
predicts that Henry's gonna take it uh I
don't know about if Henry's gonna take
it I'm just saying as far as all the
matchups this is one I didn't see coming
for Cheeto good good big Mexican uh fish
on the line for Cheeto there but
tough fight stylistically tough fight
but Martin can get he always figures it
out yeah it sounds like a great one you
know Cheetos our boy here so of course
Cheeto knock him out tough fight style
Escape very tough fight that's three
rounds
I would assume it's because the main
event is uh sugar versus aljo that's
your five rounder oh yeah so yeah it has
to be through or sometimes they do
sometimes they do it but I doubt they do
it for this one
yeah
all right uh this as well
so Alyssa gross Alexa Grosso and
Valentino chefchenko part two is booked
for September 16. it's not gonna be a
pay-per-view it's going to be a UC Fight
Night
that's interesting even though it's
Championship you know fight
and it gracios I think the pound for
pound number one female fight I don't
know really yeah without a minute Nunes
is out
interesting
and this one so it was a new boy Korean
zombie dude I didn't like hey you want
one more he's like yeah I'd love one
more say less here's Max Hollow he's
gonna knock your [__] face into North
Korea the thing is why North the thing
is like because he doesn't want to be
there I know so
so max Holloway called out Korean zombie
for whatever reason he wants to fight
creams on and queen zombie back in the
day called out Max Holloway too he
always wanted to fight but this is
styles for yeah yeah styles are great
yeah back in the day dude sign me up
yeah now how dare you Max always as of
right now A minus 1 000 favorite which
is crazy and honestly I figured it'd be
a bigger fan really yeah damn that's so
cool when I saw her I'm like why are
they doing the screen zombie what did he
do he wants to fight though sir he's
like I'll take it yeah
and they're gonna headline it so it's
going to be it's gonna be a great fight
I don't know what's gonna happen I know
it's gonna happen Jen I pray for my I
know I know he's your boy and we love
Korean zombie here I just hate this
fight for him Max always gonna beat the
[__] out of him
after
stylebender beat per hair the last time
I believe anything's possible now
but this is different though right both
guys are there yeah at least Alex and uh
Izzy are like both in their Prime you
can like kind of figure that one out
this one you're like what the last one
why would they do this
yeah well it'll be a great fight
next I mean just give me an ass whooping
but sure all right we'll Bet On It
it's a great fight this one's so yeah uh
Ian Gary Ian Machado Gary versus uh Jeff
Neal great the 292 card is six so fun uh
Ian Gary who I you know he's the next
it's tough to compare to Connor right
because they're talking about such an
outlier but if there's anyone that's
close with the confidence and the skill
this Ian Machado Gary is such a [__]
Savage I think with and what he did to
Rodriguez man the kids ready for this
you know Neil's no punk but if you were
to give I think it's a good matchup for
Gary I think he does get it done but
after you beat Neil now it's we're going
Sizzler if you're Ian Gary fan then then
you're up there with the big boys
you'd see a guy potentially making run
for for a title shot you know
um early 2024 mid to 2024
he's on the right path they've done it
right with him
he's excited to watch he's only 25 too
yeah super young
uh the next match up let's go here your
boy Corey sandhagen versus Umar narmaga
made of same night as Nate Diaz and uh
Jake Paul August 5th I mean Corey saying
Hey how do you not love this guy so he's
ranked was he top four now and Umar
maybe top 15 was Umar 11.
questioning is four all right Umar is
11. name another guy in those top
[__] in the top
five that would take on Umar like this
does nothing for cool nobody wants you
more everyone yeah he's a nightmare
absolutely [__] nightmare and just
Corey San Diego and his thought when he
came on food truck was he goes I'll
fight anybody when I asked him about
um you know marab he won murabba Richie
he goes I want to fight the toughest
guys before I'm a he goes hey I
shouldn't be Champion if I can't beat
all the guys and he goes and B if if I
haven't fought those horrible matchups
when I'm Champion I'm not gonna hold the
belt long so I want to do it before I
become Champion so he wanted marab he
wanted Umar nagamet off he's gone the
hardest dude he's just a straight up
he's one of the last few samurais that
we have in the sport hats off to him
everyone's like oh you get killed he's
getting like all this hates like careful
you asked for
man's never fought a guy of his caliber
not even close stylistically very tough
fight for Umar
so this is core San Diego's Instagram
and him you know talking about the Umar
matchup
guys hey I know you know you saw the
announcement fighting August 5th against
tomorrow I'm gonna get mad off I'm
getting a lot of haters saying why did
you fight this far down in the rankings
he's gonna beat my ass blah blah blah
two reasons one umar's a great fighter
and I'm not trying to be World Champ if
I'm not the actual best there you go
entire world so if I do tomorrow is a
great Challenge and I accept it and
number two because I'm a beast [__]
that's why
[Laughter]
his personality is starting to come up
yeah he's starting to flourish we got
the mustache popping too I love this I
love I think he beats him
ah yeah I'm sorry very tough fight but I
think you beat them
our next cool fight on 292 as well Rob
font versus uh song God damn that 292
might be the best card we've had hot
second
it's a great fight
and also
Rosa majunis
she's going up to flyweight now to fight
uh that girl man and Fiore
she's back she's going up and wait yeah
she this girl is very tough to fly with
well she's coming back yeah
uh here's a quick one so Jake Paul
versus Nate Diaz it was supposed to be
eight rounds it suddenly got changed to
10 Rounds they all agreed to it are they
still doing in Dallas because I thought
the weed stuff they must have figured
something out they must have behind the
scenes
so 10 Rounds confirmed this by Jake Paul
I feel like this definitely favors Nate
if he's sparring but Nate tweeted uh not
too long ago uh I'm good with a yeah
he's good with eight with eight with
eight yeah
um
I don't I I don't know how I feel about
this fight yet did you see Nate's
sparring partner this guy came out no it
was like I beat the [__] out of him he
said that yeah what a douchebag that's
very strange thing to do yeah yeah I
don't know
um well
if it's old school day you know if it's
a version of Old School Nate like the
longer goes the better because he has
ridiculous cardio I assume Nate gets
ready for this
um it doesn't matter if it's 20 rounds
if Nate's not taking it serious he's
gonna get knocked down do you think
since he's fighting Jake Paul he's
taking it seriously or do you I think
nade is a Fighter's fighter and takes
every fight serious I don't we've never
seen him take the fight off so I would
assume Nate's ready to go all I'm saying
the caveat there is if nape for whatever
reason whatever is going on in his life
goes I can beat this guy man I don't
need to train too hard he's gonna get
knocked out
it's me devastating for his fan base
devastating to get knocked out by a
YouTuber
who just lost he's getting the bags
though he's getting the bags
um all right so this is gonna be on one
of the undercards Nate's boy Chris Avia
he's gonna be fighting Jeremy Stevens
The Box National boxer Chris yeah I mean
yeah
he was in the UFC for a little bit
um he didn't do that well in the UFC
I looked at his boxing record here
so he's three and one I'm thinking of uh
somebody else okay yeah Jeremy's he had
a draw with the Aldo
when he boxed
and it's like a [__] Mack truck he
hits crazy hard yeah
but uh yeah they're fighting and that
was from Ariel's show I remember seeing
that that's cool
um
so shot rachmanev
he posted something on was it Twitter
yeah
because you know Kelvin gaslin said he
want to go back to one 170. so shop
caught Ramona put this post up and this
is like in May somewhere
is that should I be the one to welcome
Kevin back oh Kelvin back to 170 not a
tough fight for Kelly Kelvin said he
accepted and he's down to do it that's
an awful fight for him I mean shotgun's
just crazy but also
I mean this is before all the kids were
on social media and stuff like that me
and Mark were talking [__] to each other
on social media and then we took you to
DMS and I was like all right let's do
this date and he's like I'm in say less
let's talk to Dana we both talked to
Dana and Dana was like that's not how
this works you don't make matchups on
social media and just assume we're gonna
sign it he's like we have different
plans for both of you guys
he's like it's not how this works
maybe it works this way now I don't know
yeah I guess it depends on how much
steam it gets you know
it's just a tough fight for Calvin it's
a obviously it's gonna be a tough fight
alrighty Anthony Smith who was just on
the show he's going to be rematching
Ryan span for UFC that that oh that's on
the max Holloway Korean zombie Main
Event Smith won before submission I
think is a joke but uh yeah they're
gonna rematch all right we love Anthony
Smith here
yeah and uh this real quick it's a
boxing one how much money this [__]
Canelo making it's not a three fight 100
million dollar deal with PBC and he's
gonna fight apparently he's gonna fight
Jamal Charlo yeah I love Charlie Brown
The Skit with him which is awesome I was
the last fourth brother or whatever
third brother
uh and this this is kind of old people
already saw it Jon Jones and Francis and
Ghana at pfl they're kind of like sizing
each other up and yeah this is old but
the thing is is it it's it's so old but
the thing is I know you've been in uh
Hong Kong but the thing is
what's stupid is uh
it's just Honey dick in us just give us
blue balls like oh this could happen
they were in the same organization for
three [__] years it never happened
yeah it could happen here's my thing I
don't why can't it happen
why can't it happen ESPN is in business
with UFC pfl is in business with ESPN
why doesn't they do a code promotion
it's an ESPN fight night don't have to
be a UFC don't have to be a pfl maybe
that's brought to you by ESPN they have
the money get it done why not just do a
one-off of Francis Jon Jones
if I'm UFC I want Jon to fight Francis
and shut them up I'm like really you
want to do this you know what John will
do to you Francis if I'm UFC I have all
the confidence in the world and John
beating Francis I hope all right let's a
ruin pfl's number one product where they
put all this money into them yeah we'll
fight you
UFC you both represent each identity
right go ahead and fight ESPN put
together John will let you do this one
off go ahead and break this dude that's
what I would do
you know you know Dana wants to squash
all competition that would do it
yeah I'm pretty sure they're super
confident in John too yeah anybody would
be after you see that zero ground fight
I don't get why it's not possible it
can't happen besides the egos
it's so funny how they're like I wish we
could have this fight such as they were
in the same [__] organization the
past three years just chilling
clearly nobody want to get it done
on the UFC side
alrighty here's a picture of Aleister
Overeem that recently surfaced so I
posted this Olympic Rim I
mean Olympic cream yeah
no longer Uber ring maybe he's cutting
down to 185
I don't know it looks crazy though so I
had the picture up but it just went away
somewhere they just have some random
dude on there this might be it hold on
this is the sake of our he's the one
that started I think Pride
and I just Rising
um I'm not even sure if he does Verizon
anyway you saw the picture
yeah he's so thin
let's see if it's here again
no
it was all over the internet I actually
called him ozympicream
most people see this also Ultra and
you've been in uh Korea
okay nevermind there it is right there
100 second one is there it is yeah that
looks crazy
good for him man when he get big like
that you want you want you want
longevity in life you want to lose
weight man
uh so these are just highlights from
other shows this is from
I'll just show you this yeah it's not
the no no uh audio though just in case
oh you know like a wheel kick interact
them out under a kick something like
that you boom yeah
oh there are the pictures
oh this is funny so this is
John annik on this show Anakin flooring
podcast and then
he's at his mom's house I believe this
is where is this where anik falls in the
chairs
this is him getting pissed off at his uh
audio dude crackle pop it's like cereal
right now that sounds awful but yes but
Neil Darius there's a lot of angles of
course on his side of things in this
matchup oh my God man I can't even take
it like I'm not even ignoring it anymore
yeah somebody typed that is [__]
brutal I can't even do the show like
that I'm not even playing I just heard
oh my goodness oh my goodness
what is that it's only someone eating
it's not necessarily as audio dude it's
just like some audio issues that are
happening during the broadcast that I
just continue to do the show like this
oh my God
we can stop the [__] down no maybe it
just stopped all right let's continue so
there are plenty of Darius angles on all
of them yeah I do have a dark side you
see it come out when we have technical
issues that sounds beautiful right now
so we will get was here already long ago
he's all you can see right for saying
like what the [__] I know he's like oh
dude I will kill you
oh
[Laughter]
you gotta keep all this can you hear me
can you hear me
yeah we can hear you
[Music]
you got to keep all of this
in a row
funny dude yeah
is that it brother hold up brother let's
see
oh I wanted to show you this real quick
this is uh
racial Rachel ostevich who's obviously
in the UFC for a while so she started
and only fans finally she's making a lot
of money I wonder what she's been
waiting for
I thought I could have sworn she did it
before but I guess did she start her own
website yeah she'd make a ton of money
yeah and uh
so remember
we saw her in a picture with some other
dude before yeah right but now she's
dating a comedian
and this is the comedian I don't know
to oh he's from Hawaii I know this guy
yeah so this is who she's dating now
that's cool yeah
that's them together
good for him
yeah
Mahalo my man
and uh oh this is the last one I wanted
to ask your opinion about this so uh
Mike Perry was on Joe Rogan's podcast
and then Joe Rogan said like if Conor
McGregor you know how they faced off
Conor McGregor and Mike Perry during
bqfc he said that if they were to
actually fight in bkfc it would do like
at least a million pay-per-view Buys so
I wondered what you thought about that
mmm BK so it's bare knuckle Conor
McGregor Knuckles bare Knuckles their
pay-per-view model though he gotta buy
it's a bit of a nightmare I bet I don't
think you'd do a million it's too tough
now if it was on if it was Bare knuckle
and it was Mike Perry and Conor McGregor
fight in the UFC with their promotion
and their marketing and they're known as
a pay-per-view model yeah it does over a
million but if it was just on bkfc not a
chance
yeah I wondered about that
students like you have to download the
app like we've done it here we've done
fighting it you have to download the app
you got to watch it on the production's
not great you know
I think it'd be surprised
you know
I mean Connor's on ESPN for free every
Tuesday night and it's eating [__]
now he's not fighting but it's still
Conor McGregor yeah he's on the show
every Tuesday
I think they're having like maybe 200
000 views now
you know and I I think it's it's run a
little thin with con you know he'd have
to get a win you know having fun hot
second
just because he's doing bare knuckle and
Mike Perry for us we love him he's a
legend around here for the average fan
like wait what's he doing you know
I think I don't think you'd do a mill
yeah
oh yeah I was thinking about that I
[__] actually do a mill even I
thought it was like maybe like 500 600.
and that would be a home run for B Camp
see although there have to pay Connor
Godlike money to do that yeah you know
all right kids that's it all right kids
you got a fight night this Saturday Sean
Strickland versus absolutely
all right let's give a good fight for
Sean Strickland hopefully he's a slight
favorite you got Kevin Lee fighting some
Russian news 20 wins I mean a tough one
uh uh lipsky we love here Max Griffin
tough card all right it is what it is I
will be in Covina uh Covina Covina
Covina California brand new small little
theater there it's a Laugh Factory they
just took it over your boy uh I think
I'm the first headliner there that's
this Thursday Friday Saturday Covina
California is going down June 29th
through the July 1st that is this
freaking Thursday Friday Saturday David
Lucas is will be with me as well the
great David Lucas uh we have a bunch of
other dates coming up shopping friends
at the Ice House in Pasadena is July
28th we have spoken coming up skank Fest
in Vegas Niagara Falls but I have a
bunch of more dates that'll be announced
soon for 2023. all right kids oh the new
thick boy uh jerseys dropped this Friday
at 9 A.M you got the the Pinstripe you
got the Grays we have hoodies we got
hats all new stuff uh these are straight
up MLB quality jerseys so get you some
available at thickboy.com all right all
right kids be nice each other love you
see you around
see you this weekend I'm out